did you pray
each morning before your illness no
no i didn't but my grandmothers were
both
religious and
if i had a religious question i could
ask them
um so there was it wasn't like there was
no god for me before
and i've and i've been to church and i
and my mother died in 2007
i pray to her daily i would say so
my praying has changed since i was ill
it's become
more dogmatic and uh
yeah it's become more dogmatic and also
i have a relationship with a
personal god now that i that has
that has grown in nature so i'd say i've
always been spiritual
i'm more spiritual now i take it more
seriously now i understand it better now
um i think that it's
not an option i don't think it's an
option for people to live a life
a fulfilling life meaning
that people cannot live a fulfilling
life if they don't have god
in their life yeah i i think so you know
as
a spiritual relationship with uh
higher power is necessary what's the
difference between
religion and spirituality well religion
is
dogma you know so the church and
and uh all the readings the bible all of
that that's dogma
spirituality is a feeling that god is
there with you
and that if you give him space he'll
tell you what's right and wrong
that's spirituality and so you could
and they overlap they can't overlap
but for some people they don't uh
there's an intellectual understanding of
god
that's not a spiritual that's not a
personal understanding of god
and i think you need a personal
understanding of god to really
make your move yourself forward